let's stick with the phones we will go
next to our caller from the 778 area
code caller from 7 7 8 Euron who's this
I was just wondering Oh Dan we're just
wondering what you think Larry elder is
wrong on what do I think he I mean what
do I think he's right on I just the
guy's an ideological right-wing or I
can't I can't think of anything I agree
with him on oh well yeah I haven't seen
too much of and I just saw that you
mentioned him in a video when you were
talking about black people who didn't
think to Rick we're basically
Republicans when you were talking about
Kenneth Owen right so I guess you just
don't agree agree with him on unethical
anything yeah yeah I mean listen I you
wanted me if the audience was interested
I could go and look at a list of Larry
elders positions and do like a
point-by-point rebuttal I don't know
that anybody's that would be that useful
I think the context that I was sort of
mentioning him in was this idea that
there is a contingent of the right that
is particularly eager to celebrate black
conservatives because they are
statistically rare and part of it is
wanting to show how open-minded and not
racist they are by finding some black
conservatives that they can point to but
that the ideas of these individuals
really don't have anything to do with
their blackness they're just bad
right-wing ideas you know so that
there's really nothing unique about them
but there's nothing I mean if I could go
back and look specifically at what larry
elder believes i can't think of anything
offhand that I would end up agreeing
with the guy on actually thinks that
would be a pretty interesting video just
putting that out there
also I recently saw a clip of Qi Tian I
don't really finished the video but I
heard them mention basically I think
they were referring to when
conservatives were saying that they were
furious that Samantha's viewer was
called a Ivanka hump or a [ __ ] rather
he's always
yeah Trump and I was basically saying
big Trump quite frankly yeah God yeah
and I was basically saying that
Republican policies reflect on how sort
of unfair and discriminatory they are
towards women do you have any idea what
she might be talking about there I'm
sorry you're saying that that Samantha
bee says that Republican policy is
discriminatory towards women
I know Ana Ana Kasparian
when she was talking about this issue
she said that you know conservatives
don't actually care about women in that
that's reflected upon Republican policy
yeah oh I completely agree I mean I
don't know what Ana has in mind there's
a bunch of different ways right I mean
restricting access to family planning
services and abortion services in a way
that that's dangerous for women and it's
also psychologically damaging for women
efforts by groups of white men to
control women's bodies the there's
endless ways in which Republicans claim
to be doing things for moral reasons but
they are just more ways in which women
are they are indifferent really to the
to the circumstances women find
themselves in but if I don't know what
Ana meant by it you'd have to ask her
okay am i singing it in my singing right
now are you seeing anybody oh yes I am
thank you all right thank you very much
for the call didn't know if there was
gonna be a follow-up on that not sure if
he was he wanted to ask me out on a date
or something but yes I am seeing someone
right now why does everyone want to
throw that in at the end they'll ask too
serious question yeah I asked about your
love life I don't know I don't know it's
very very unusual but hope I answered
that one for you